[Música]
bem se fosse mais simples ser candidato
num processo eleitoral no brasil
você seria candidato melhor se você
tivesse certeza que um dia candidato
ganhariam as eleições você seria
candidato
pois bem imagine você um dia chegando
para a sua família e anunciando família
eu vou ser candidato nas próximas
eleições o que acontece na cena do
próximo capítulo
eu nunca tinha imaginado nesse lugar e
com certeza os meus pais não sonharam
isso pra mim mas a verdade é de que
todos os dias quando eu acordo cedo vou
para o famoso ponto de ônibus esperar o
ônibus que leva o trabalho está num
ponto que não tem aquele telhado que me
protege da chuva e eu confesso que
houveram mais de uma vez em que eu
chorei de raiva porque não tinha aquele
telhado para me proteger da chuva
enquanto estava esperando o ônibus
chegar mas eu não quis ficar só esse
sentimento e 15 um pouco mais fundo e
esse é o ponto
são sempre os mesmos sobrenomes são
sempre as mesmas famílias a cada seis
políticos hoje que ocupam um lugar no
congresso de 10
eles têm representantes na política
também
e aí eu começo a pensar que realmente as
grandes transformações que a gente
acredita que o brasil ea política no
brasil precisam passam por pessoas
comuns
a gente adora ouvir histórias
inspiradoras mandela pessoa comum com
origem comum a muitas pessoas no mundo
que fez coisas incríveis extraordinárias
mala mesma coisa
eunice primeira mulher eleita senadora
no brasil num processo democrático
eu acredito em pessoas comuns que estão
fazendo coisas extraordinárias
agora você já parou
pensar por que você pensa tão mal assim
da política ou se você já fez alguma
coisa para pensar diferente sobre o que
de fato é e significa política na sua
vida e no seu dia a dia
parafraseando o famoso filósofo política
é a busca da felicidade do coletivo
esse política de fato é a busca da
felicidade do coletivo
a gente tem tanta dificuldade de achar
propósito nesse lugar porque não faz
sentido para tanta gente fazer e se
ocupar de política nós somos fazedores
de política todos os dias enquanto
acordamos vivemos no nosso trabalho nos
relacionamos com os espaços da sociedade
fazem sentido para nós nós estamos
fazendo política e até quando você nega
política você escolhe fazer política
a política da omissão vídeos números de
abstenção do direito de votar nas
eleições de 2016
mais de 20% do eleitorado que pude
exercer esse direito escolheu não fazê
lo com certeza vocês já ouviram dizer
que na política não em si não existe
espaço vazio
isso significa que o espaço que lhe é
concedido por direito senão ocupado vai
ser ocupado por alguém
se a gente tivesse que pintar uma foto
hoje do que é o congresso brasileiro e
você com certeza pode já ter ouvido isso
de algum lugar
ele é um homem jovem é mais tempo branco
que usa terno e tem uma cara marrenta
com certeza
e aí a gente olha para esse lugar e fica
procurando a diversidade de raça porque
em seu brasil o brasil é um país diverso
você fica procurando as tribos onde
estão os indígenas representados dentro
desse lugar onde estão as mulheres onde
estão os jovens não me representa uma
frase que com certeza você já falou hoje
eu vi alguém dizer que no meu processo
de buscar ser resposta e contribuinte
era mais eficiente para isso que tanto
me incomoda
eu deixei a carreira no mercado de aço
depois de formado em administração de
empresas os meus pais não podiam
acreditar quando eu entrei em casa com a
notícia vou candidatar nas próximas
eleições
a meu ver isso não é sério não se está
brincando com a gente mas por que você
vai fazer isso de verdade é o que pra
era o que pra mim naquele momento fazia
sentido então resolvi dedicar a minha
energia e tudo o que eu tinha de força
dentro de mim para poder construir um
projeto de novo partido no brasil ser
candidata e hoje lidera a organização
política partidária no estado de são
paulo
mais que isso de tudo o que eu tenho
aprendido eu tenho observado ensinar e
apoiar que novas pessoas se coloquem
nesse lugar e não tenho que passar pelas
primeiras experiências que eu tive que
experimentar
parece difícil imaginar que existe algum
tipo de falha felicidade e realização
nesse lugar mas sim quando você se
conecta com aquilo que você realmente
quer ser como resposta para o mundo isso
faz sentido e energia vem pra você e
todas as vezes em que você precisa para
não desistir e continuar ali talvez
esteja olhando pra mim agora dizendo
assim eu já tô cheio desse assunto
alessandra eu nunca perdi nenhuma é
série e nenhum capítulo novo do
rasgadinho eu entendo tudo sobre a
situação política inclusive o congresso
brasileiro é bem parecido com isso e eu
sou aqui um formador de opinião do meu
sofá de como é que funciona esse jogo
você não conhece resultados e nunca
assistiu a nenhuma dessas sedes
talvez você tenha sido então game of
thrones que também é uma coisa que
ensina de maneira bem votada como é que
funciona o jogo da política
o jogo da política na verdade do dia a
dia tem muita similaridade com essa
série que eu acabei de compartilhar aqui
com você mas aquilo que você vê na tv
apesar de ter antecipado que realmente
acontece no dia a dia têm elementos
invisíveis que você não consegue ver
isso mesmo
coisas que você não enxerga como por
exemplo as reais regras do jogo
quem faz as regras do jogo são as mesmas
pessoas que detêm os partidos políticos
no brasil e desde 88 não se faz uma
eleição com as mesmas regras da eleição
anterior
então esse é um jogo que se aprende
jogando e todas as vezes em que nós nos
colocarmos no lugar de gomes e de quem
não quer jogar a gente está fazendo
parte do jogo
quando a gente assiste aquelas séries ea
gente aprende maneira lúdica como é que
funciona o jogo do poder
algumas pessoas podem outras pessoas se
frustram ainda mais
mas o que eu tenho visto é uma multidão
de jovens espalhados pelo brasil pessoas
comuns pessoas que não são da origem
daquilo que eu gosto de chamar de filho
cra cia
são pessoas como eu e você que se vêem
possíveis no processo de colaboração
dessa revolução criando espaços como o
movimento acredita que tem uma meta de
10 anos para contribuir com a renovação
do congresso
a rapidez que é uma rede de ação
política que forma líderes que se vem
servindo nesse lugar
essa é uma coisa que até hoje espanta um
pouco a minha família mas eles se viram
como parte do processo de apoiar porque
quando eu mostro aquelas imagens de
figuras como mandela como mala como a
própria eunice
eu diria que essas pessoas elas merecem
o mínimo do nosso respeito e se possível
o nosso apoio e aí falando sobre essa
revolução que eu acredito que é
importante e que está dado para o brasil
você pode me dizer assim eu não me vejo
fazendo política sou chamado para o
empreendedorismo eu acredito e muito no
empreendedorismo e é exatamente com você
que eu quero falar nesse pé disse você é
chamado para o empreendedorismo então
empreenda uma campanha você vai ter 45
dias pra abrir uma empresa porque todas
as campanhas elas exigem a abertura de
um cnpj e o processo é o mesmo como se
você fosse abrir um negócio para vender
algum produto palpável
você tem 45 dias para abrir uma empresa
fazer do seu único produto que tem como
o advanced as propostas ser o mais
conhecido do segmento que você escolheu
atuar você ainda vai ter que lidar com a
máquina do fake news que sim o seu
produto é legítimo original e virtuoso
se você fizer tudo isso encerrar sua
empresa num período de 45 dias e tiver
tido seu principal produto com milhares
e dezenas de seguidores ao final você
pode empreender no brasil com o que você
quiser
alessandra eu não me vejo chamado o
empreendedorismo e nem pra política eu
sou um líder
onde eu vou eu sou chamado para liberar
acho isso genial que você lidera na sua
casa no seu bairro é você reconheça que
você tem um chamado para a liderança
então seja um candidato porque você vai
expandir a maior capacidade de acumular
liderança quando você vai dormir muito
pouco vai precisar ser lembrado por
alguém de que você precisa beber água
você precisa se alimentar até que você
precisa no banheiro porque 45 dias para
conversar com dezenas de milhares de
pessoas
comunicar sua mensagem convencer dos
mais diversos e múltiplos pensamento de
que você tem a capacidade sim de
representá los ainda mais lidar com a
persona que a figura que criam a
respeito da candidatura não quer dizer
que ela seja você de verdade afinal o
candidato é de todo mundo
você ainda vai aprender a superar as
frustrações da vida
sabe aquele seu melhor amigo que torce
por você bate palma e diz que seu fã
porque você agora tem coragem de ser
candidato pois é talvez talvez ele não
lhe ceda a traseira do seu carro pra
colar um adesivo com a sua cara
e nessa hora você vai olhar para ele
dizer mas a gente não tava junto não era
isso que eu tinha que fazer para
melhorar o brasil me colocar nesse lugar
sim mas cada um vai se entender
colaborando de alguma maneira e você
chamado para a liderança testado no
lugar de candidata vai realmente poder
responder para você e para as pessoas
com você se você foi chamado para
liderar de verdade
as campanhas políticas no brasil não
estão para aqueles que querem brincar de
fazer campanha
as regras do jogo são feitas
historicamente pelas mesmas pessoas e
assim como a gente vê o que a gente quer
no netflix ea gente só vê o que as
televisões abertas querem que a gente
veja ignorarem que elas determinam que a
gente veja a gente precisava criar uma
sede fixa da política a gente precisava
olhar para a câmera e verdes votando e
falando aquilo que a gente realmente que
acredita que nos representa em todos os
momentos que isso precisa ser oferecido
para nós
a dinâmica é divertida mas o preço a se
pagar para chegar e fazer isso nesse
lugar
é um preço muito alto e doloroso mas
nenhuma das figuras que a gente
compartilhou e viu as fotos aqui fez
coisas incríveis sem ter pago um alto
preço por isso
a coisa que eu mais acredito é que de
verdade ressignificar a política é um
papel e uma responsabilidade que está
para as pessoas comuns
a fundação obama recém criada abrir um
novo processo para os inovadores cívicos
pessoas que estão têm iniciativas no
mundo que impactam esse lugar da
política serão aceleradas empoderadas
por essa organização
a gente precisa admirar e apoiar
iniciativas como essa porque é uma
virtude necessária preocupação e
ressignificação desse lugar chamado
política
ela está em cada um de nós e uma vez
colocada para fora precisa ser apoiado
fortalecido para aqueles que se conectam
com essa verdade
bem eu me coloco nesse lugar e até então
tem feito sentido continuar seguindo e
encorajando outras pessoas a se
colocarem aqui também
de tudo o que eu acredito e eu defendo
hoje eu acredito que realmente a grande
transformação de brasil e de mundo que a
gente está sonhando ela nasce em
corações corajosos que humildemente
querem do a sua vida como uma oferta de
amor pra esse só
o que a gente tanto deseja que seja
melhor usado e melhor compartilhado com
justiça igualdade para todas as pessoas
é tudo o que eu tenho pra vocês hoje
aqui